The global Netflix hit The Queen's Gambit debuted just over a month ago.
The fictional series follows the rise of chess prodigy Elizabeth Harmon...
..as she battles addiction, sees visions of chessboards on the ceiling,...
...all while checkmating her way to victories in the male-dominated sport.
In just 28 days, The Queen's Gambit was viewed in 62 million households, a Netflix record.
The on-screen matches igniting a new off-screen interest in the game.
Chess had already seen a boost in popularity beginning in March....
...when the coronavirus lockdowns began.
Chess.com, a popular chess app hosted 142 million games in February.
By April, that number jumped to 192 million.
Arnold Schwarzenegger, NBA star Giannis Antetokounmpo and president-elect Joe Biden...
...getting in on the action.
Why don't we play some chess?
What do you think?
I'd like to play chess.
I've been playing on my cellphone.
With the release of The Queen's Gambit,...
...Americans are streaming more chess content than ever.
At Chess.com this month, more than two million new members,...
...many of them, like the star of the Netflix series, are women.
And it's not just an online craze.
Since the show's premiere, eBay reports a 215 percent increase in sales of chess sets and accessories.
Tani Adewumi first showed us his skills when he was eight.
After his family escaped Boko Haram in Nigeria,...
...Tani went from chess novice to New York State Chess Champion in a little over a year.
While the star player in the Queen's Gambit is fictional,...
...Tani says the game holds very real life lessons.
For all those now getting into chess, any advice?
Never feel like you lost a game because you never lose.
You only win and you learn.